never Trumper George F will takes a high
dive
sadly off the deep end his piece of the
Washington Post on Wednesday was
headlined Trump is no longer the worst
person in government now can you guess
who is no it's not no no and that's got
through it no no it's vice president
Mike Pence low-key self-effacing and
loyal Mike Pence how could that possibly
be
well George Will has a conspiracy theory
and it's a whopper he wrote the
following Mike Pence with his talent for
toady ISM an appetite for obsequious
nests could trump new become America's
most repulsive public figure well will
theory is that Trump picked pence
because America would have such a
revulsion for his VP it would take the
heat off the president himself but
there's a tiny little flaw in this
theory what makes pence so repulsive
exactly well it's proof will sighted the
post calculations that during a cabinet
meeting pence praised Trump once every
12 seconds for about three minutes with
such hideous comments as quote I am
deeply humbled I guess you can't say
that now will doesn't just find Pence's
humility repulsive he also seems to have
some kind of issue with Pence's faith
will wrote quote pence one of
evangelical Christians favorite pinups
Gen you flex at various altars as the
Mabo Craddock spirit and the vicious
portion require well will was similarly
offended that pence would call himself
honored by the presence of former
sheriff joe arpaio at a gathering in
tempe arizona the veep called Arpaio
quote a tireless champion of the rule of
law according to will Pence's repulsive
humility piety and respect for the law
make him quote the authentic voice of
today's lickspittle republican party
well wills absurd accusations were
gleefully picked up by the feedback loop
on the left as an opportunity to smear
the vice president who is Mike Pence I
don't know you know he doesn't really
seem to have
or convictions or beliefs beyond
whatever Donald Trump's decided they are
striking this balance trying to be you
know the man that will inherit the
mantle of Trump but at the expense of
his own persona there are two kinds of
vice presidents there are those who are
accused of being so out for themselves
and nursing their own ambitions that
they're not serving the president who
picked them and there are those who are
accused of being slavishly loyal lap
dogs and so forth Mike Pence has decided
to be the former and there's a ladder
that is he is a Titanic and I mean
Titanic fraud he is the most obsequious
of all of trumps cultists in the cabinet
we have never seen such slobbering
civility by high government official in
this country than we do with Mike Mike
Pence consider the source my friends
it's Pence really the worst person in
government and why are the pence haters
lashing out now it's very interesting
let's ask the vice president's former
press secretary Mark Lauder match slap
of the cheese the chairman of the
American Conservative Union and
democratic party activist Chris Hahn
mark let's go to you I've known Mike
Pence since oh gosh when he was in
Congress he used to actually fill in for
me occasionally on radio we still joke
about it
I found that from George will actually
really sad he's had an unbelievable
career as one of the premier columnist
writers in the United States he's
obviously doesn't like Donald Trump
that's fine but I thought it was filled
with such low blows and I just say I
wasn't angry about it I was actually sad
about it it's not surprising let's
remember that in 1986 he wrote a column
that called then Vice President George
HW Bush a lapdog here's a decorated war
veteran a hero who would later go on to
be a transformational president so I
think George Will has a problem with
vice presidents who serve transit or
transformational presidents of the
United States and to get to use a
baseball term that I know George would
like you know the best players in the
world missed seven out of ten times and
in this case I think he struck out
swinging at a pitch in the dirt well
let's go to you Chris there were
I think there were overtones in this
column that George wrote and he was
picked up by a lot of media figures as
happens on people knows someone writes
something we're talking about it and he
talked about how he Gen you flex at the
altar it it was it was imbued with all
these religious overtones and it seemed
really condescending to me condescending
about Mike Pence's faith almost
questioning Mike Pence's faith oh you're
not a real Christian we didn't write
that but you could read between the
lines and that's right and I say this is
someone I like George will and you know
a lot of people don't want to charge
will who watch this show I actually like
him I've known him for a long time and
it pains me to say this but I thought
the column was beneath him and filled
with low blows and not at all in any way
illustrative of the man who might pen
says and he's a wonderful person well
look a very effective vice president
well the column got picked up broadly
because the vice president decided to
plagiarize Richard Nixon during the
Watergate scandal that morning that
column was released and I think look
while I do think that tone was harsh
it's not like George will said his
opinion doesn't matter because he's
about to die which is something that's
been set inside the White House these
days so I think we got a back off on
this is such a bad thing let's face it
the Vice President is the boot licker in
chief in this administration right now
he is the one who praises the president
most he kisses his butt most and what's
sad about it is that in 2020 this
president will drop him from the ticket
because this president cares about
ratings and who he picks for his vice
presidential candidate at the convention
will be the biggest ratings night of
that week so mr. pence you might want to
stand up to this president a little bit
because he's not gonna stand by you yet
nice gonna take a swing at this before
he does so were you concerned about Vice
President Biden taking on Obama to you
because I'm trying to remember oh wait
he never did like when good Vice
President Biden take on Obama for
screwing up the Obama care website for
screwing up Benghazi for screwing up the
the trailing of journalists for hounding
people who applied for IRS status when
did
and come out and challenge Obama's abuse
of power when did he do that like that
you didn't criticize Biden for it
because you know that vice president's
role is to support the President of the
United States go yes why is Mike Pence
being attacked you know why he's being
attacked because it's about pride and
ego of these never Trump writers they
can't really admit that the agenda is
the most conservative agenda we've ever
seen that he's actually doing what he
said he would do and you know what Mike
Pence is doing a man with a 99 percent
voting record with the American
conservative record Union I don't know
what he ever got wrong but I guess he
got one thing wrong one time I mean all
the time was the Congress each that you
get attacked by these people because
they think we're deplorable they don't
think we have any moral standing to make
the case that that what Donald Trump is
doing is the right thing and I'm telling
you mark when you Hilary talked about
the basket of deplorable --zz Obama
talked about the bitter clingers George
will in this moment has more in common
with their view of middle America from
from where Mike Pence came then he does
with the conservative voters across
America who said we fed up with these
parties we're gonna go for someone who's
gonna take a wrecking ball to the old
Washington way it's elitist its snobbish
and it's unbecoming it's unbecoming and
so millions of Americans who support
this administration are horrible awful
racist xenophobic terrible people really
good luck building a movement on that
idea this is not the first time this has
happened the same thing happened in 1980
when the American people turned their
backs on the mainstream Republicans who
had another preferred candidate and
elected a strong leader like Ronald
Reagan they did it again in 2016 in and
president Trump and the elitists can't
get over it doesn't doesn't keep you
know its thesaurus and facilities by his
bed perhaps you know George will you
know it's always it's always the seven
syllable words that you know like nobody
everyone has to like look I'm on TV okay
that's fine and I like yes that's kind
of quirky about well I like that but
had Chris my concern here is that the
timing of this is curious they're
striking out on Trump Trump's numbers
are going up so they think they can gin
up something on pants I mean Trump's
numbers are improving day by day by day
because the results are there for the
American people
well nobody's really gonna base their
numbers aren't Trump on what pence is
doing I just think that a George Will
had a feeling about Mike Pence based on
what happened in New Mexico when he went
to me in Arizona when he went out there
with Joe Arpaio look I think a lot of
people have reasons to think Joe Arpaio
is somebody who should not be touted by
the Vice President or the president Joe
Arpaio disobeyed a court or Joe Arpaio
what he did out there was racist in many
people's eyes so I think George will
sees that he says look this is not the
Republican Party this is not the
conservative movement that he grew up
with that he likes to see and he would
like to see Mike Pence be the backbone
of conservatism to President Trump
because let's face it President Trump
became a conservative about four years
ago Mike Pence has been a conservative
his entire life so if Mike Pence is
becoming more like Donald Trump instead
of bringing Donald Trump more like Mike
Pence then conservatives are gonna have
a problem with that and I think that's
what George Will was lashing out about
it and look you want people to talk
about it you better say some crazy
things well you're doing good at saying
some crazy things and I just all I would
say is this which is do we want to win
or do we not want to win I know the
president talks about if we won enough
we're tired of winning okay but listen
here's the deal
conservatives are actually getting more
done and we're in a window well we can
get even more done than a czars gonna be
the one of the big rock stars of this
administration the HHS secretary is not
usually someone who gets a lot of
attention I've known him for 25 years he
clerk the master Prince brilliant he
could have been a cabinet secretary at
many he could have been a anything he's
doing this because we've got to get this
prescription drug stuff this has to be
tackled the right way he's gonna do a
lot more
he got Bob white who's got Wilbur Ross
these are these are example these are
these are people of real substance who
are doing really hard work and I think
it really irks people who are never
Trump errs and a lot of the Democrats
because it's like they're throwing stuff
up against the wall and I'm telling you
when Steve Schmidt because he ran a
great campaign with
Cain and Palin when he wasn't trashing
Palin by the way Steve Schmidt said this
today let's watch we've listened to this
guy for many many years in this country
on his moral high horse assaulting to
dignity of gay people across the board
his moral preening is famous throughout
the land the same vice president who
just swore in rick Rennell gay american
to be the new ambassador to germany okay
so so if you were a true if you're if
you're if you're a faithful Christian as
he is he's by nature homophobic I mean
this is where we are in the country you
can't disagree on some core issues
without being a terrible awful rotten
xenophobic home it's just a litany of
can I jump in on the timing here exactly
public is very different hold on I'm
happy that we're Cornell's going to
Germany personally I think it's a great
thing for the country and for the
administration and for and for America
but let's look at the timing of this it
is because if you look at all the polls
the right track wrong track it's
improving for the first time in a decade
Trump's numbers get better and better
and you know the only place where Trump
is a little weak is foreign affairs and
he's having all these accomplishments
what the Democrats are seeing is this
big blue wave is starting to starting to
go away and this is why they're starting
to panic Chris I want to play a bite
from you from our friend Nicole Wallace
who's always been very charitable toward
people who make mistakes she was on
MSNBC today and she got very upset about
Sarah Sanders let's watch how do you
resist the temptation to run up and
wring her neck why can't she just say if
a staffer said that we're gonna get to
the bottom of it and she'll be fired how
do you resist the temptation to run up
and wring her neck she went I shoulda
let her in she apologized she said just
reyga's the tensions getting to her I
used poorly chosen words for that I'm
sorry I mean honey they're talking about
the comment made by Sadler in the White
House that about about McCain this was
an unfortunate comment made made in
private that we don't even live that way
a minute guys we do not you know look
Matt Matt yes Wallace apologized
Sadler should apologize and the White
House should apologize for that
statement about an American Hero John
McCain I disagree with John McCain on a
lot of things but John McCain is an
American Hero
who should be respected and who should
not be talked about by this
administration as he has been not does
enough of all this first of all you
don't know what happened in a private
meeting none of us knows what's happened
their moral judgments that come in I
think John McCain deserves his peace and
quiet at this trying time we all believe
this but he still has a voting record
and it's okay to talk about it and it's
okay to talk about him opposing the
president's nominee to be the head of
the C letter about there Matt Matt
there's so much nasty rhetoric out there
that needs to calm down and it starts at
a time starting president we see that
see pac-man where your where your
communications director sense that
you're going to this is about Michael
Steele we're gonna be there I mean I
think Chris we can go back and I can
cherry pick the the bright lights of the
left in the entertainment industry and
the media but now we're threatening to
choke people we're gonna blow the White
House you know if we're gonna talk about
vitriol I mean check out my Twitter feed
anytime of the day it doesn't bother me
it's like whatever my vid I don't care
but don't pretend to be like these
shrinking violets John McCain is
American Hero John McCain is it had a
conservative voting record on a lot of
issues he disagreed with the President
on a lot of issues and I believe he said
there was last year don't feel sorry for
me I'm gonna fight my fight don't feel
something right he's not someone who
wants to be treated with kid gloves at
any point he's a tough guy ball in hand
who can handle an amazing person all I'm
saying it's really easy for the White
House just to say you know what that was
that was unfortunate we apologized to
the McCain family for that they're going
through a very trying time not just in
facing higher family oh stop it Chris
let's not change Megan McCain besides
subject from the podium
you see look we have policy
disagreements with these people at MSNBC
Michael Steele goes on the TV all the
time calls the president the worse
things and then he acts like he has the
moral high ground
the same thing for my friend Nicole and
the same thing for these people who
attack all of us Republicans who stand
with the president
we're different when it's coming from
the White House Matt you used to work
there you know this I'm proud works
there and I don't think you should
entrance you should smudge the
characters of these good people you
can't do it mocking and before
characters mocking people's faith if it
were done against an Islamic individual
or people who are not like considered
the horrible awful hateful people Mike
Pence has been mocked repeatedly by the
popular culture that our fans and
fanatics of the left and it's been
tolerated and it's a wink and a nod they
think Christians are all stupid
knuckle-dragging troglodytes anyone who
supports Trump is an idiot that's what
basically George will thinks and I think
it's backfiring so the left has got to
try a different tactic if you want to
win well bring these people into the
fold not insult them we're out of time